we're in zone is this part of some game
what are you talking about I put you
here yeah this is where guys go when
dumb girls like you don't realize they
should like us in a romantic way and the
way we want them to and exactly when we
feel it
[Music]
oh girl have I been through this this is
the classic tale of what some men like
to so wrongfully call friends let me
tell you a story passed down from many
generations of female identifying
cupcakes in my family help
[Music]
princess cookie and the land of the
friends sexiest chocolate chip filled
princess that's good yeah sure she loved
to laugh and clean and have fun and look
sexy all the time entirely there's my
buddy and favorite person to play with
sir macaron hey Mac hey Mac and me stay
best friends forever so we can always
play games and have fun together now
let's go play chef best friends forever
great okay it's great down here actually
lots of snails and water and thanks for
throwing me in hello these two have been
playing since the day they were born
their time together was special cookie
felt seen and they just got each other
in cookies mind nothing could ruin their
friendship
but she was wrong okay I have three
kings two elves one sugar cookies that I
have all the hearts for you yeah you
have all my hearts oh I know I mean I
know it wasn't a hand I just I just
wanted to tell you that you have my
heart okay thanks I mean that's great
and all and I care about you too but
like as a friend what let's play another
round
I haven't heard from Mack in like four
weeks this can't be because I don't have
romantic feelings for him can it that's
it I'm putting together a royal search
party and finding we won't give up until
we find Mack
[Music]
everybody wait here I'll investigate
myself hello Mac what are you doing here
what is this place it's the friend zone
you put me here when you didn't return
my feelings of love but I do love you
yeah but not the way you want me to
friendzone is this part of some game
what are you talking about I put you
here yeah this is where guys go with
dumb girls like you don't realise they
should like us in a romantic way and the
way we want them to and exactly when we
feel it because um excuse me
dumb girls just because a girl doesn't
want to kiss your sticky faces doesn't
mean she's not worth having as a friend
the fact that you won't disappear from
your friendships just because it's not
exactly how you wanted to be makes you
powers no friend owes you anything you
can't deal with that then you're not
worthy of their friendship in the first
place
Mac this place is just as fictional as
the lands we make up in our games you're
better than this
what do you say are you man enough to be
just my friend you know what I think
I am well I'm staying here forever and I
hate all girls now okay happily ever
after now as well as this tale went for
cookie this is also a cautionary tale
doesn't always go this way so he was
lucky that Matt was able to see her
point and talk openly about it you
should also be able to respect his
feelings and be understanding if you
need some space just to know that if
your friend can't see the value in your
friendship without you being
romantically interested in him sadly
he's an alien friend worth having good
luck kurwa we believe in you until next
time friends stay strong
[Music]